[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to I'd like to know
this is our question and answer program
where we get the privilege of answering
your questions from the word of God my
name is CA Murray and I'm in the com
company of Pastor Daniel Miranda
colleague fellow traveler uh associate
speaker at Secrets unsealed your your
your titles are getting long man you you
are growing in the Lord and we praise
the Lord for it good to have you here
it's good to be here Pastor in this
wonderful program that we believe is
becoming one of my favorite of our
favorites it is indeed one of our
favorites for a number of reasons first
of all we like to study the word of God
uh secondly we like to hear what's on
your mind and it gives us a chance to
interact with you Pastor Bohr Is On
Assignment he is out doing the work of
the Lord so he is not with us so we are
left to carry on which we shall do Under
The Grace and goodness of the Lord we've
got about bunch of questions number of
things we want to say before we we begin
the questions number one we want to wish
you seasons greetings at this time of
year when we are praising the Lord and
remembering him in All Things two we
want to make you this guarantee which we
do just about every program that
guarantee is that we will answer your
questions from the word of God we
believe that it is a little late in
Earth history to be bantering about the
will and way of man we need to hear a
word from the Lord so we promise you
that if you take the time to write in a
question we will give you an answer from
the word of God if one can be found
we'll find it and give it to you the
questions are getting rather long when I
say long the stack of questions are
getting along so if you don't hear your
question please be patient with us
um labor with us just a little bit we're
getting to them just as fast as we can
but a lot of questions are coming in
from all over the world and we want to
get to them all and we don't want to
skip any of course if we see
duplications uh we'll take care of that
but we want to give due respect to all
of your questions so we will answer them
from the word of God if an answer can be
found and we make you that promise
should you like to get in on the fun
you can do so by writing to us at TV at
suntv.org that's TV at some tv.org
we will take your questions we will put
them in this rather impressive stack and
we will get to them just as soon as we
can we pledge to you so we want to
launch out into our program Pastor if
you will have a word of prayer we'll get
to our first question okay
let's bow heads for prayer
dear heavenly father
we are told in the spirit of Prophecy
that we should not dare to open your
word without prayer amen and the reason
is because our minds are carnal we
cannot discern spiritual things
so we need the aid of your Holy Spirit
to help us delve into the scriptures
and be able to answer these questions
as you have revealed it in your word we
pray in the name of Jesus amen amen and
amen
um
let's see our first question comes to us
from Peter and we thank you Peter we
don't know where you are writing from
Peter but we thank you for being a
viewer this is an interesting question
uh that comes up from time to time when
we go to First Corinthians chapter 15
verses 51-54 and I've had many many
opportunities to recite these particular
texts of scripture uh my last church I
did 117 funerals wow so uh we went
through this many many times
um behold I show you a mystery we shall
not all sleep but we shall be changed in
a moment in the twinkling of an eye at
the last Trump for the trumpet shall
sound and the dead shall be raised
Incorruptible and we shall be changed
for this corruptable must put on
incorruption and this Mortal must put on
immortality so when this corruptable
shall have put on incorruption and this
Mortal uh has put on immortality uh then
shall be brought to a past the saying
which has been written death is
swallowed up in Victory all right then
he refers us to Luke chapter 20
verses 25 and 26 which says but they
which shall be accounted worthy to
obtain that world and the resurrection
from the dead neither married nor given
in marriage
neither can they die anymore for they
are equal to angels and are the children
of God being Children of the
Resurrection
given this his question is the following
at the resurrection we are changed and
received incorruption and immortality so
why do we eat from the Tree of Life ah
to to sustain life like Adam and Eve did
well it's a very very good question
and I think the the bottom line of the
question is to Define
what does the bible teach about
immortality
I think that's that's the main point in
the question well I understand it and I
believe that's where the word of God
says
um is that we believe the Bible teaches
us as we and we are Seventh-day
Adventists believe in conditional
immortality
what does that mean that immortality is
not innate in US
but we receive it on account of
condition
so for example if we go to to Genesis
chapter 2 verses 16 and 17
we read here that God created a perfect
world
and God's will for Humanity was that we
would live eternally
death was not in his plan
but he gives here a condition
in Genesis chapter 2 verses 16 and 17
uh the Bible says and the Lord commanded
the man saying of every tree of the
garden you may freely eat
but of the tree of the knowledge of Good
and Evil you shall not eat
for in the day that you eat of it you
shall surely die
and then in chapter 3
verse
um
here verse 22 it says then the Lord God
said behold the man has become like one
of us to know good and evil and now
unless he put out his hand and take also
of the tree of life and eat and live
forever
so actually what has the or what gives
him mortality that the way that the Lord
has provided immortality for man was on
condition of obeying his word and
partaking of the Tree of Life
and the same thing will be at the end
where the Bible says that the mortality
will put on immortality that means God
will give us uh Immortal bodies and we
will not die anymore as long as we trust
in the provisions that the Lord has
given us to have eternal life so even in
a perfect world
we will have to partake of the tree of
life every month the Bible says that
we'll go to the city uh every month and
why do we have to go every month because
every month the tree of life gives a
different fruit a new fruit a new fruit
yes you know well said
um we we are
um
we come up incorruptible
but God has designed that we we partake
and I think it is because throughout the
thesis ages of Eternity we have to
remind ourselves and we'll be reminded
that our our
longevity our sustainability comes from
God it is still a gift of God now a
couple things happen
um we do this because we are at peace
and I love that last chapter of a great
controversy she talks about PC you know
in the universe and everything of that
piece there is harmony with God so we do
this in acceptance of the will of God
um
we know that there's not going to be sin
a second time
a sin will not rise a second time there
will be no Discord a second time so
there is a perfect Unity between us and
our Lord and his desires and our desires
so this is a
a an activity that we gave we engage in
almost Daniel as praise to God exactly
um uh as acknowledging his lordship and
as acknowledging that his uh that our
immortality is is still a gift from God
yes for God alone has immortality that
does not change we are granted
immortality uh as long as we walk with
God now we know that we will always
welcome to God praise the Lord because
sin will not rise a second time but it
is an homage that we pay to God
throughout the season's age of Eternity
and it's not going to be a burden to do
so it's going to be a blessing to do so
amen amen yes um
you know the only one that has
immortality
the Bible says is God in first Timothy 6
16 he's the only one that has
immortality that is part of himself yes
it's innate in God but
um but the beings that he creates
that he creates to live forever
they we don't have not even Satan has in
Native mortality yes even his life
depends on God
so we we never get out from dependence
upon exactly amen and and I say it that
way uh because it's convenient to do so
but it's not it will not be a burden you
know when you're a Christian here it's
not a burden to serve the Lord It's not
a burden to stop uh my my six days of
work and rest in Christ on the Sabbath
day it's not a burden because I I want
to do that well uh these things we will
want to do because they are part of
God's will for us throughout the thesis
ages of Eternity amen uh we will not be
uh we will not see corruption but our
our our immortality is is sustained
through the power of God uh through the
fruit that we eat once each month amen
I'm looking forward to it now amen yeah
first having a new fruit every month
ah and praise the Lord
um
this next question Daniel my pastor my
friend
um talks about something that comes up
again from time to time a lot of
confusion about Easter Passover and Holy
Communion some envelope Adventists
celebrate Easter
and some Churches have Easter services I
would like to know the difference and
whether Easter is a Christian or Pagan
celebration uh and that may be the key
to the question yeah because Easter is
not mentioned in the Bible
and um uh we cannot say it is it is it
has become a Christian celebration but
its Origins are not so
um
communion is a little different it's a
lot different
it's a lot different right uh and
perhaps let's start with community and
work our way back to Easter yes uh
communion Christ has told us to do and
as off as we do it it's in remembrance
of him so communion is a is a different
kind of thing I remember when I was
going they used to call it a mini
baptism that's right they used to say
that over and over again but Christ
asked us to do this
um to recommit ourselves to him if there
are any little infractions we can
confess them and and and get them
straight just priority the communion
service there is an ordinance of
humility and then there is a a symbolic
drinking of the blood and eating of the
body of Christ and we do that now the
idea of once a quarter actually we kind
of got from the methodists you know we
you know there's no bailable text that
says we got to do it four times a year
some Churches do it every week of course
maybe a little much you know when you do
something that much a cantaloupe becomes
a little mundane a little Samo but um we
kind of got it from the Methodist and it
works for us
um but it's it's not in the same
vein or in the same boat as Passover and
and communion maybe you've got something
you want to add before I go on yes
exactly
um communion took the place of Passover
in the New Testament a Passover
commemorates the the Deliverance of of
Israel from Egypt from slavery and we
see the institutional Passover in Exodus
12. there we see that God institutes the
Feast of Passover in commemoration of
the great deliverance from Egypt and
also pointing to the great deliverance
from sin and sin so that that's Passover
when Jesus came he instituted the Lord's
supper or communion instead of Passover
because he was the true Pascal lamp
correct so there was no need to practice
Passover anymore after Jesus Christ died
on the cross and the connection comes
because it was done during the Passover
season correct so the spring of the year
and was doing the Passover time so
there's a kind of
invalid connection that's always going
to be there because the first communion
happened during that time that's right
no Easter is a common holiday today and
then some some Churches celebrated in
commemoration of the resurrection of
Jesus Christ but uh we don't find
anywhere in the Bible
where we should have a holy day to
commemorate the resurrection of Jesus
Christ now it's good to remember the
resurrection of Jesus Christ I think
it's a special moment but we don't have
a command like Passover or communion
that we should do it yes and I've heard
some of my evangelicals say friends say
in justification of keeping Sunday that
also is a commemoration of the
Resurrection you know so you can kind of
stack them one top of the other and kind
of pile on
the key is that there's no biblical
command to do so we have a Biblical
injunction to to celebrate holy Union
amen Christ said that so that was
instituted uh Passover we know of the
legitimacy of that particular uh event
but Easter has no biblical underpinnings
um it is something that people do
um and then there's there's the the
first Sunday after the full moon after
the vernal equinox you know and uh uh
the the first full moon the first Sunday
after the full moon after March 21st
there's all kinds of ways that it that
is calculated uh but um suffice it to
say there is no biblical command to do
it so it is it is separate it is
something that has been grafted in over
the years and and a lot of uh our our
Christian friends do so but I don't see
any call for Adventists to to to do so
per se that's right um and um certainly
there's no call in the Bible to do so
mm-hmm
very good
all righty we're moving along uh yeah I
know this is
this some Stan
or Stan or stand or
please explain Genesis chapter 9 26 and
27 does the tenth of Shem refer to
Dwelling Places every time I've seen
tense in Scripture it refers to Dwelling
Places or homes let's let's go to the
text so we get some context and uh then
we can deal with it Genesis chapter 9
and we're looking at verse 26.
26 and 27.
you want to read it or yes please okay
so we read from Genesis chapter 9 verses
26 and 27 from the new King James
version the Bible says and he said
blessed be the Lord the god of Shem and
many and make Canaan be his servant
may God enlarge jaffet
and may He dwell in the tents of Shem
and may Canaan be his servant
[Music]
all right
um
I think the the the
person that Stan has has pretty much
touched on this as it is may God enlarge
japheth and dwell in the tents or houses
or lands or kingdoms or realm of of Shem
so tense is a general term here yes to
show the relationship of one person with
the other he's going to dwell in his
land uh maybe be tents may it be houses
tents is just representative of the fact
that one person is going to be connected
with with with the other correct and we
see that this actually happened because
uh jeffeth
he he grew more in territory than Shem
and according to historians the Greek
and the Roman Empire they come from
jeffith and they actually conquered the
land of Israel yeah the shemites and the
territory that the shemites occupied in
old but so the the Jaffa fights
conquered the military
but the shemites conquered spiritually
in the gospel
well said
um so it just as I stated it just refers
to the relationship uh of one to the
other one is going to be over the other
uh and one is going to have control of
them yeah and it's interesting that um
we we find that
actually the colonizers the ones that
really enlarge and expanded the
colonization in the world where the
Europeans and it is believed by some
historians that that the European
nations they they come they're the
descendants of of japheth
so
of the three sons of Noah this is the
one that was going to enlarge even more
so we say for example Spain yeah
Portugal Great Britain those were big
colonizing countries they colonized uh
uh America and many islands and other
parts of the world
there are a lot of places in the world
that speak English speak Spanish speak
Portuguese because of uh these countries
and they're they're going out uh in
portions of Africa also it's certainly
important that the Caribbean and South
America uh so we we see that prophecy
fulfilled in a broader sense
um through uh what happened with the
European countries vis-a-vis the rest of
the world
okay
um moving along Dan do you want to take
a read at this next one sure so this
next question comes from Aaron Aaron
Kane Aaron Karen Kane
it looks like he wrote on a Sabbath
because he says hello and happy Sabbath
my question is in Jesus's statement
found in Matthew 24
verse 20 and we're going to read that
Matthew 24 verse 20 the Lord said but
pray either your flight be not in the
winter neither on the Sabbath day
then the question is this
why would he tell us to pray our Exodus
not on the Sabbath
could the answer be if we fear for our
lives and run away on the Sabbath day we
are in essence concerned for our lives
when we should not be
would that be not trusting in God
so the bottom line of the question is
why did Jesus commanded us to pray that
our fly might not be on the Sabbath day
but what are the implications of that
okay well let's first let's take a look
at the end of the context for this
statement which of course is found in
the preceding verses
um
um and I'll start at so let's see
um quickly at verse 15 therefore when
you see the abomination of desolation
spoken of the Prophet Daniel standing in
the Holy place and that of course is a
whole program on its own uh whoever
reads this let him understand let those
who are in Jerusalem flee to the
mountains let him who's on the housetop
not go down and take anything out of his
house let him who is in the field not go
back and get his clothes but woe to
those who are pregnant and to those who
are nursing babies in those days and
pray that your flight be not in the
winter so we're talking about the
inevitable destruction of Jerusalem and
the scattering of the people so this is
a very pragmatic statement by the Lord
yes that when you see the Roman
standards coming when you see them in
place
leave the city don't go back to get your
clothes don't go to the bank and check
out money you know uh
leave flee and of course we find out in
this bit of Prophecy that all of the
Christians who follow this this uh
statement none of them lost their lives
amen so it's it's saying trust in the
Lord don't go back and make provision
for yourself yes so when you see this
happening now mothers who are pregnant
it's going to be tough on you right
um those who have small children it's
going to be tough on you nursing those
are who are nursing babies in those days
and pray that you don't have to get up
and go on the Sabbath
pray that your flight be not in the
winter this is just very practical uh uh
information or counsel that Christ is
giving pray that you can when you see
those standards it's a Monday or a
Tuesday but that it's not on Sabbath you
know so that your Sabbath the rest is
disquieted while you're running for your
life yes uh and um
um
oh there's sort of leaving my mind oh oh
that'll not be in the winter and that's
obvious you don't want to be running for
your life in the winter it'd be better
to run in the summer you know kind of
thing so this is just very practical
information and crisis giving uh because
uh he looked down to the civilian time
and New Jerusalem was going to be
destroyed and uh he's he's trying to
help those who are going to have to flee
to prepare themselves for that time
exactly and and we see
we see in the in the story of the
destruction of Jerusalem that day I
believe they were celebrating uh one of
the feasts if it were not the Feast of
Tabernacles which when everyone was
gathered and congregated in the city so
I also think of you know if if you had
to flee on the Sabbath the enemy would
come and would find you yes you know
congregate it uh for you it would be
more difficult to flee and also just
just the stress or the anxiety or you
know the rush of the moment that would
not be appropriate I mean you would not
be able to enjoy yourself very well no
not at all in that day so as you said
this is very practical they're not deep
theological implications the the main
point or an important implication that
we find here
is that the servers would be would still
be binding
after the cross that's the key yeah
that's the key that if the Sabbath would
have been changed or uh moved to another
day it would be
sort of indicated in this particular
text but uh when this was written we're
talking The Book of Matthew so we're 20
plus years after the death of Christ the
Sabbath is important and he's talking
about a time ad70 uh which is many many
years after the death of Christ so the
Sabbath is still important so you pray
that you don't have to leave in the
winter or on the Sabbath so one of the
things that we can say is that this this
text is one that buttresses the idea
that the Sabbath was still in effect
after the cross amen amen so
um we need to
follow Jesus's instruction we need to
pray we need to make provision for when
that time comes
I wouldn't say any material provision
but spiritual provision prepare
ourselves mentally spiritually because
Jesus said that it was going to happen
and as you said
this this requires an entire program to
explain the abomination of desolation
yes how it was fulfilled in 1870 and how
it will be fulfilled in our days but we
know that it refers to the enactment of
a Sunday law yes in in the for our time
yes yes yes and you you get a little
hint in verse 21 for there will be great
tribulations such as not been seen since
the beginning of the world up until the
time that little phrase kind of Peaks
its head up several times in the New
Testament all talking about the time
just before the end so this is an
allusion to the fact that God's people
near the end of time are going to have
to flee also as they did uh back in uh
the days just after the cross so
um uh again this is this would be a
whole program on its own but certainly
we we can see that the thing is we're
going to have to trust God we're gonna
have to put our faith in God our hands
in God's hands and um uh let him lead us
hopefully uh we don't have to leave on
the Sabbath or some other day but
whenever we have to leave we've got to
trust God to deliver us and he will
deliver us that's why I love Daniel
chapter 12 verse memory stands up and
and delivers his people amen well
brothers and sisters we have come to the
end of a program and the end comes so
very very fast with these programs we
pray that you have been blessed and that
you have heard something that has been
of benefit to your spiritual walk we
love to answer the word of God our time
has now slipped into eternity we ask you
in closing to remember Christ and we
wish you all God's best bye bye we'll
see you again soon
[Music]
foreign